democrats in the house rammed through a
january 6 commission investigation
cryptocurrency takes a serious hit and
joe biden continues his war with the
teleprompter
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from big tech with vpn
i trust visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first i've been telling you
for a while
that you might want to put some of your
money into precious metals i've been
telling you that because the reality is
that the government can inflate the
currency
or the government could theoretically
raise taxes or the government could
you know basically undermine the
economic system and the full faith and
credit of the united states dollar a
good way to hedge against that is
precious metals well
turns out i was right on about on all of
those things all those things i was
right this is why you should have
checked out birchwold like five years
ago but you should still do it right now
like now's a very good time
to go check out some precious metals
i've been telling you again for five
years and that was back when gold was
1300 bucks an ounce now it's up over
1800 bucks an ounce because gold
and silver thrive on uncertainty
inflation is coming taxation is coming
so i'm telling you again
if you haven't reached out to birch gold
to diversify part of your ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira
do it today text benz 4747 47 get a free
information kit
i'm protecting your savings with gold i
buy my gold from birch gold they have an
a plus rating with the better business
bureau countless five star reviews
over ten thousand happy customers talk
to them have them help you safeguard
your investments text ben
to 47 47 47 when you make a purchase
before june 30th birch gold will send
you a signed copy of my last book how to
destroy america in three easy steps
for free while supplies last again text
ben to 474747 protect your savings today
and of course when you make a purchase
before june 30th you get a free copy
of my last book how to destroy america
in three easy steps alrighty so
yesterday the house rammed through
along party lines essentially a january
6th commission there were 35 republicans
who voted to create the january 6th
commission
as well most republicans voted not to
go along with the january 6th commission
according to the wall street journal the
house passed a bill on wednesday
authorizing a bipartisan independent
commission
to investigate the january 6th the
pro-trump assault on the us capital but
the proposal could stall in the senate
after gop leaders in congress and former
president trump
urged republicans to reject it for the
second time in a week house republicans
found themselves facing a contentious
vote that trump has framed as a test of
their loyalty
even as the party tries to focus on more
unifying topics criticism of the biden
administration and winning
next year's midterm elections which of
course is the reason why they are
pushing a january 6 commission
to ignore the politics on the side of
the democrats who are pushing the
commission the reason they're pushing
this
is because they wish to have this bleed
over into the 2022 midterms because the
reality is that joe biden has not
governed well
the democratic party is not in high
favor with the american public
right now on a number of issues
democrats are really struggling and so
they have to redirect toward trump
and thankfully for them trump is still
there to fight with
but it really is about january 6th for
them if they can continue to focus in on
january 6 if they can continue to focus
in on trump
this allows them to avoid the
consequences of having to look in the
face of their own governance because
remember democrats right now are in
control of the house
and the senate and the presidency so
2022 naturally is going to be a
referendum on the party in power this
always happens midterms are a referendum
on the party in power the way that
democrats are hoping to shift that math
is by making instead 2022 a referendum
on trump
who will have been at that point out of
power for two full years and so what
they're going to attempt to do is say
well you know how about however bad we
are those republicans they're the ones
behind january 6th you all remember how
bad january 6th was and so we're going
to do a full investigation
and our investigation is going to focus
in not only
on failures systemic failures that
happen right with the with the capitol
police
or with the federal law enforcement the
the
failures are going to focus in the
investigation is going to focus in
on the rhetoric of people in the
opposing political party and we are
going to attempt to link that rhetoric
to the events
of january 6. the republicans know this
democrats know this which is why
democrats are pushing it and republicans
are pushing back
against it now could there be an
investigation
of january 6th that makes sense sure but
it would actually fall under
what congressional investigations
usually do so to understand what a
congressional investigation
like this would actually look like were
it designed to elicit
something useful you actually have to
look at the general purpose of
congressional investigations
so 2003 there was a report for congress
that was put out by lewis fisher a
senior specialist in separation of
powers from the government
and finance division this is from the
congressional research service talking
about what investigations typically look
like and
one of the things that is clearly true
is that there are really only two
specific functions that congress is
supposed to perform when it does
an investigation one is that it could
theoretically be performing
legislative oversight of the executive
branch so there was a failure inside the
executive branch the 911 and so
you need to look at how the system is
structured fbi
cia were they talking to each other
there was this byzantine wall that was
designed to prevent for example domestic
law enforcement from using material and
evidence that they could not use in a
courtroom
and that wall had to be breached in
order to allow intelligence sharing
between agencies right that would be a
good reason why you'd have congressional
investigations
congress created these agencies and
wanted to make sure that these agencies
are performing
their duties under the law right that is
a normal oversight investigation
then you have a legislative powers
investigation in other words in other
words
the the goal would be to look at
legislation anew it's sort of connected
to oversight but the idea here is
we're trying to figure out how the
system actually works in practice now
because we might actually want to think
about
whether or not we need to change the law
whether there are legitimate
legislative concerns that undergird the
investigation now what congressional
investigations typically are not
supposed to do and they've really run
a foul of basic kind of black letter law
here for decades on end
they're not just supposed to be phishing
expeditions where congress just calls
random people in front of them and then
has them tested by
testify about things that have nothing
to do with these specific functions
remember congress is a body with a job
it is not just a bunch of people who are
supposed to sit there and talk to you
about random stuff
right we have an entire commentary that
is designed to talk to you about random
stuff and to talk to you about political
implications
of events that are happening around you
that is not what congress was designed
to do
congress was supposed to be your
legislative plumber they were there to
fix issues they were there to make the
system worked
to make sure the system worked well if
congress
was was doing an investigation of for
example steroid use and baseball there
are a lot of folks
including people like me who said i
don't like steroid use in baseball but i
have no idea
what this has to do with congress what
in the world is congress doing having
hearings on steroid use
in baseball makes no sense congress
isn't going to legislate on that
particular issue
congress really has no interest on drug
use in a particular sport
it's kind of a weird thing for congress
to be doing however 911 is a sort of
different story okay so january 6th
lies along the 911 lines in the sense
that there are actual government
oversight functions that need to be
performed so for example
if there were members of congress who
were actively involved in criminal
behavior
were there rules that were preventing
them from being involved in that
criminal behavior
or were there members of the executive
branch breach their duty and therefore
there needs to be an oversight function
of the executive branch
right all of that would be legitimate or
if you wanted to look at the law
right how exactly is it that the white
house works with the
with the speaker of the house to
determine security protocols on capitol
hill does that need to be changed in
order to prevent a future january 6.
right that sort of stuff would be
legitimate but what everybody
understands here
what everybody knows is that the goal
here is not that
the goal here is to link every
republican that democrats can find
with january 6 because this was the goal
immediately after january 6th
right upon january 6th happening this
immediately shifted from everybody of
good faith of good faith and good heart
is horrified by what's happening
we're all there we all remember it we
remember that mitch mcconnell got up on
the floor and he
reamed the protesters he spoke out
against trump's language between
november
4th and and january 6th you'll remember
that
the it was mitch mcconnell who oversaw
the certification of the election
vice president pence oversaw the
certification of the election i know we
all want to forget about the fact that
the process actually ended up working
that many of these republicans ended up
voting for the certification of the
election and it was indeed republicans
in every state
every battleground state had
high-ranking republicans who are helping
to oversee
these election results right georgia was
all republicans overseeing the
certification of those election results
so the system works you may not like how
the system came out
but the system did in fact work and
republicans
worked within that system it was
republicans again who oversaw that
system
on the federal level as well right what
actually happened on january 6th
is that president trump gave a rally at
which he made claims about the election
that were not true
but he also told people and they always
cut this part out with the ellipses
to peacefully protest and then go home
and yell at their congress people about
the election
okay so trump did not encourage people
to breach the capitol building
then a bunch of idiots decided it would
be a great idea what if we breached the
capitol building
in an attempt to either hunt down
legislators or to just delay the process
or to be idiots and then hundreds of
them were arrested
so the real failure there would have
been for example the capital police
the real on a systemic level if you were
going to investigate this properly it
would be about the capital police who
did not deploy the cat like all of
that's legit but that is not where this
investigation
is going again when it comes to
congressional investigations
subpoena power is generally tied to
legislative power or oversight power
those are
the powers that are supposed to be
exercised here and the reason i keep
coming back to that
is because it is fairly obvious that
that is not where this is going
again according to this paper from the
congressional research
service judicial rulings
do recognize a greater sweep to
congressional authority in 1927 the
supreme court faced a situation where
congress looked not into the activities
of people in the private sector but
rather the conduct of the executive
branch and the court stated
that the power of inquiry with the
process to enforce it is an essential
and appropriate auxiliary
of the legislative function congress
couldn't legislate wisely or effectively
in the absence of information but again
it was designed to to proceed along the
lines of legislative purposes this is
the governing supreme court precedent
legislative purposes okay so we'll get
to it in a second whether the house is
actually pursuing legislative purposes
first let's talk about the fact that a
lot is happening at your front door
right now a lot is happening on my front
door
right now now as things begin to open up
you get more packages on the front on
the front porch you're getting more
neighbors stopping by and saying hello
life is becoming more colorful and more
wonderful again this also means a lot
more activity on your property and this
is why you need your ring
devices so much happens at your front
door if somebody stops by or something
is going on outdoors around the house
ring lets me know it's peace of mind
anytime knowing that my home is
protected to get ring alarm for yourself
go to ring.com ben it is the perfect way
to start your ring experience there are
a thousand reasons why protecting your
home
matters to you for me it's the fact i
have a bunch of little kids running
around my property
at all times and i need to keep an eye
on them protect your whole home with
ring alarm it's a powerful affordable ho
home security system you can easily
install yourself
ring has security products for every
corner of your home inside and out best
of all you can see it in one
simple app you can keep an eye on your
home no matter where you are right from
your phone if somebody stops by or
something is going on
ring will let you know it's peace of
mind anytime knowing that your home is
protected there's a reason
one of the first things we did we got to
floor up put the ring devices on the
house start protecting your home today
with ring alarm go to ring.com
ben get your ring alarm security kit
today build the system that's right for
your home have it up and running in just
minutes that is ring.com
once more ring dot com slash ben so
again legislative purposes would be
the language right because if you are
talking about
just criminal investigations we have
full-on
branches of government that are designed
to this we have the doj we have we have
local law enforcement
we have state law enforcement we have
all sorts of law enforcement bodies
which is why
again there are hundreds of people who
have been arrested over the january 6th
riots
okay so back to this january 6
commission this is now being used by the
media as a litmus test
of whether you are okay with what
happened on january 6 and that of course
is not correct
you can point out that the january 6
commission does not seem
like it is directed at eliciting
information that is going to
allow congress to fix the process right
it seems more
like it is designed to elicit a
political response just in time for the
midterm elections
and that is not an unfair point because
everything in washington dc is politics
and to pretend otherwise is simply silly
senate senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell declared his opposition to the
house bill earlier
on wednesday he joined house minority
leader kevin mccarthy and dismissing the
commission is unnecessary and unfair
mcconnell said in a speech on the senate
floor that after careful consideration
he'd come to the conclusion the house
bill was slanted and unbalanced
he points it to other investigations
underway by law enforcement officials
and in congress biden of course supports
the commission
he's going to need 60 votes to advance
in the 50-50 senate
that means at least 10 senators would
need to vote with all of the democrats
that probably is unlikely
even some kind of wavering republicans
people like susan collins have said they
don't really like the way that this
commission is structured particularly
because
it allows democrats the full capacity on
the commission to select all the staff
well as we saw with the mueller
investigation who you select for your
staff makes an
awful lot of difference in the final
product that is produced by any
quote unquote independent body the
bipartisan problem solvers caucus had
endorsed the commission according to the
wall street journal saying the plan had
won support for more than 75 percent of
the 58-member group but it is strongly
opposed by mccarthy and other house gop
leaders who say that it is
counter-productive
and also too narrowly focused on the
events of january 6th right so the
republicans are also saying okay fine if
you want to do this as a political thing
like how much is rhetoric contributing
to political violence in the united
states
then you do need to make this a truly
bipartisan investigation
you need to look at things like for
example the congressional baseball
shooting or like the
blm riots over the summer or like antifa
over the summer how much does rhetoric
contribute to violence if that's really
what we're talking about here
if that's the direction you want to go
with the january 6th commission if the
issue is not
what systemically went wrong to allow
the walls of the capital to be breached
if the issue instead is how closely is
rhetoric tied to action
well then you do have to broaden out the
scope of the inquiry that is not an
unfair argument
the language agreed upon by the
democrats and a couple of republicans
particularly john cacco from new york
states that the focus of the commission
will be quote the domestic terrorist
attack on the capitol
and targeted violence and domestic
terrorism relevant to such a terrorist
attack
cadco has said that the scope could
include events that occurred before or
after the date
of january 6 if commissioners chose
mccarthy and mcconnell say the
commission should examine political
violence broadly defined including the
actual
murder of a capitol police officer who
was rammed by a car on april 2
and riots during racial justice protests
last summer
mcconnell said that he was open to
hearing hearing
arguments foreign against the commission
on tuesday and then
mcconnell sort of reversed himself and
he said that he wasn't particularly
interested
in this particular process okay so
democrats of course are jumping all over
this and they are suggesting
that this just demonstrates that
republicans don't want to hear the truth
about january 6. i think we know the
truth about january 6th
and by the way if if democrats want full
investigative power they could just have
investigated this in the context of like
an impeachment investigation which they
didn't
they decided to ram through a very
poorly and vaguely worded impeachment
charge against trump
on grounds of incitement which is really
weak t
in terms of legal speak and then they
decided to ram that through without an
investigation
so it's been politics top to bottom here
and the january 6th commission is
just as political again there could be
an iteration of a january 6th commission
that makes sense or you talk to the
actual law
enforcement officials responsible for
not staffing up
at the capitol and you look at the
response time sure you look at whether
there was a delay in the executive
branch
receiving orders to go and respond to
the crisis at the capitol all of that
could be encompassed but if this is
going to turn into a broader
conversation
about whether refusal to acknowledge
election results inevitably leads to
this sort of activity then of course you
would be remiss to
to not investigate people on the other
side of the aisle for doing the exact
same thing
and we'll get to more of this in just
one second because as always
democrat when democrats do something
highly political the media say that they
are doing it on principle
and when republicans do something highly
political democrats say they are doing
it for highly political reasons
this follows that pattern we'll get some
more of it in just one second first
let me tell you about the underwear that
currently grace this magnificent took us
i am talking about tommy john's hammock
pouch underwear
you're that much more comfortable you
can do everything better i throw it on
my other underwear tommy john is just
that good
tommy john doesn't have customers they
have fanatics fanatics they call tommy
john's hammock pouch one of life's
greatest inventions with dozens of
comfort innovations once you've tried
tommy john underwear
you're never going back they've got that
air mesh interior hammock they've
moisture wicking fabric with four times
the stretch
of competing brands with over 13 million
pairs sold people across america love
tommy john
because everything stays in place no
more sticking no more chafing tommy john
underwear has a non-rolling waistband
for the perfect fit the legs are going
to never
ride up you're covered with tommy john's
best pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee honestly it is so good that i
literally threw out all my other
underwear and just bought more tommy
john
it is that good and it also happens to
be really durable which matters to me a
lot because i throw these things in the
wash a lot
right now you'll get 20 off your first
order at tommyjohn.com
that is 20 off your very first order of
underwear and loungewear at
tommyjohn.com
and by the way they've got stuff for the
ladies as well my wife loves tommy
john's stuff as well
tommyjohn.com slash ben see site for
details
alrighty so naturally democrats are
jumping on this and saying it sounds
like republicans
are afraid of the truth well it seems
like
democrats are afraid of the truth if
they don't want to have a broader
commission based on blm
we can play this game all day long
basically if you don't want an
investigation of an issue because you're
afraid it's going to get politicized
then we can just claim that apparently
you're afraid of the truth here is nancy
pelosi clicking and clacking her way
through this one
it sounds like they're afraid of the
truth and that's most unfortunate
but hopefully they'll get used to the
idea that the american people want us
to find the truth and that is what we
intend to do and to do it in a way that
is as unifying as possible
that's why we yielded unifying as
possible if i wanted to go to another
committee i would have done it sooner
but i didn't want to go there
no what you wanted to do is get a little
bit of cover from people like john katco
so that she could pretend that it was a
bipartisan commission after making it
not bipartisan because the entire
staffing process
is controlled by democrats again you
could have had an impeachment inquiry
you did you impeached trump on this
inside of a week because it was just
so urgent to get rid of trump before he
left office like a week later
and then you held it up for several days
before even submitting it to the senate
so this is politics
all the way down and nancy pelosi
pretending to stand on principle is one
of the most ridiculous things in life
here's chuck schumer doing the same
thing
letting the most dishonest president in
american history
dictate the prerogatives of the
republican party will be
its demise mark my words
whatever that means for democrats it's
bad
for america we know we all know
there needs to be a thorough and honest
accounting of what took place on january
6th
the greatest attempted insurrection
since the civil war
okay the greatest attempted insurrection
since the civil war uh no
i mean really no the greatest attempt we
literally had two billion dollars in
property damage over the summer with
people who wanted to destroy the systems
of the united states we had federal
buildings attacked on mass
it's not even the greatest insurrection
attempt to the last 18 months
okay it was it was evil and it was
egregious and the images were
horrifying and the criminals should go
to jail it was a bunch of morons who
went into the capitol building were
promptly
dispersed and arrested within like five
hours and then the entire system just
went on as before so
no no but but again the goal here is not
real it's not about january
6th and what this is really about is
democrats attempting to
prolong the incidents of january 6th and
raise that as the specter and then
suggest that all republicans are in
defense of that
and so they created this catch-22 for
republicans either they go along with
this very biased commission that is
designed to elicit a response saying
that all republicans are responsible for
january 6th
or republicans say we're not going to go
along with that commission and then
democrats say well see they won't go
along with commission
because they're in favor of january 6.
so either way you go democrats are going
to claim that republicans are in favor
of january 6th
meanwhile democrats who are running for
senate
have decided to make a big issue out of
this of course tim ryan democrat of ohio
who
ran a very short-lived ill-fated
presidential campaign last time around
and now wants to run for senate in ohio
because
of course rob portman's seat is open he
uh he decided the best strategy here
would be to get up and shout a lot and
the media would pay attention to him
ben gods that you guys chased the former
secretary of state all over
the country spent millions of dollars we
have people
scaling the capital hitting the capitol
police with lead pipes across the head
and we can't get bipartisanship what
else has to happen in this country
cops this is a slap in the face to every
rank and file cop
in the united states if we're going to
take on china
if we're going to rebuild the country if
we're going to reverse climate change
we need two political parties in this
country that are both living in reality
and you ain't one of them okay uh just a
couple of questions on that particular
clip one
when he says that if we want to fight
climate change then we need to do the
january 6 commission i'm confused as to
how these two are related
when he starts ranting and raving about
how its disrespect to cops not to do
january 6 commission
this is coming from the same party that
has been ripping on the police as
systemically racist
for well over a year minimum i mean
actually
longer than that going all the way back
to the obama administration and cops are
quitting on mass so
you've picked an odd example of things
that are disrespectful
to the cops the media are trying to play
that aspect of this up of course they
did this a little bit falsely
yesterday there's a letter yesterday it
was released by
basically an unknown number of anonymous
capital police officers and the media
played it up as though the actual u.s
capitol police had sent out a letter
calling for the january 6 commission
the u.s capitol police immediately
denied that and said that is not correct
but not before nancy pelosi
and members of the media like olivia
beavers decided that they would pump
out the news that the u.s capitol police
had called explicitly
for an investigation in january 6th
commission
later olivia beaver's this reporter she
had to actually walk that back she had
to delete her tweet her original tweet
had something like six thousand retweets
and twelve thousand likes and it was
replaced with the tweet saying oh yeah
no it was just a couple of
anonymous capital police officers who
said they wanted a january sixth
commission
that tweet had like 33 likes because
that's the way things work on twitter if
it's if it's
information that confirms your priors it
goes viral if it's information that does
not confirm your priors
it does not mean while cnn playing up
exactly the democratic party line here
that is republicans
are choosing party over country that was
literally the chiron on cnn
which is pretty strong editorializing
here from cnn
now we know what republican house
leaders will do when confronted with a
domestic terror attack on our capital
nothing it's the most cynical and
spineless act
imaginable it's the definition of
putting party over country
because in opposing a bipartisan
commission to investigate the
insurrection on january 6
republican minority leader kevin
mccarthy is once again
choosing trump over the truth while
carving out his own profile and
cowardice
don't worry guys this is all just
journalism it's all just journalism okay
i'll get some more of this in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that if you
are a company seeking a great employee
it can be really hard to find me like
trying to find a needle
in a haystack this is why you need zip
recruiter ziprecruiter.com
dailywire you could try posting your job
at some job board then all you can do is
hope the right person comes along which
is why you should try zip recruiter for
free at ziprecruiters.com
dailywire when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
top job sites with just one click then
ziprecruiter's matching technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply in
fact zip recruiter is so effective that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within
the very first day it's no wonder over
2.3 million businesses have come to zip
recruiter for their hiring
needs and it's hard to find the right
people because there are a lot of people
out there who are applying for jobs
if zip recruiter can help you check them
out right now and they can
right now try zip recruiter for free at
zippercrew.com dailywire we've been
using zip recruiter here at the daily
wire for years
once again remember head on over to
ziprecruiter.com
daily wire while other companies
overwhelm you with way too many options
zip recruiter finds
you what you are looking for that needle
in the haystack zip recorder is indeed
the smartest way to hire
ziprecruiter.com daily wire okay so
again the entire january 6th commission
theory here
is not that they want to get to the
bottom of the systemic law enforcement
failures
the bottom line here is that what they
wish to do is castigate everybody who
disagrees with them politically and then
lump them in
with january 6th and again it's just set
up for a catch-22 the catch-22
is that you're unpatriotic if you are
against the january 6th the commission
you are in favor of january 6th if
you're against the january 6th
commission as constructed by the
democrats even if you offer an
alternative
and also if you go along with the
commission and then that bias commission
comes up with a report
saying that every republican was
complicit in january 6 which of course
has been the democratic party line
since the day of january 6. if you do
that
then of course you're also unpatriotic
so it's a catch-22 basically side with
democrats or you're unpatriotic
is the line and this holds true
throughout american public life
the the new rule from the media the new
rule from democrats is that if you side
with democrats are patriotic and if you
don't side with democrats who are
unpatriotic and that
holds true for every radical theory they
push forward
so we've seen a wide controversy break
out over the use of critical race theory
in schools
so first we actually need to define what
exactly critical race theory is and
where it comes from i've talked to you
at length about what critical race
theory is and i've talked about the
origins of critical race theory it began
basically with the thought that that
america's systems
were quote unquote institutionally
racist stokely carmichael was perhaps
the first prominent person
to talk about this in 1966 carmichael
suggested
that while the federal government had
barred discrimination on the basis of
race racism could not be alleviated by
that inequality and outcome
could always be chalked up to historic
racism and the structure of institutions
built
in a time of racism which made some
sense in 1966 when we were literally
just
exiting legalized racism and legally
imposed racism
it makes a hell of a lot less sense in
and carmichael made an argument that as
we would say in law school it was an
argument that proved too much it was too
broad in argument
his argument was that forever and always
any evidence of disparity in outcome was
evidence of discrimination
inside systems so it was it was that
basic idea that launched
the critical race theory project in the
late 70s and early 80s the chief
expositors
were a couple of people named richard
delgado and jean stefancek
they wrote an entire book about critical
race theory and laid out its basic
principles
first that racism is ordinary and not
aberrational that
everybody is racist that systems are
racist and that we shouldn't use racists
as a slur so much as just a description
of the way life is
second that our system of white over
color ascendancy serves important
purposes both psychic and material
that you are invested in racism even if
you don't think that you're invested
in racism so the system is designed to
create racially disparate outcomes and
if you defend any aspect of the system
it's because you have a deep psychic
need for such racism critical race
theory pioneer derek bell who's a mentor
to barack obama wrote that the whole
liberal world view of private rights and
public sovereignty
mediated by the rule of law needed to be
exploded
it was a world view premise upon the
public and private spheres it was an
attractive mirage
that masks the reality of economic and
political power in other words
basic things like private property and
individual rights these are simple masks
for white supremacy
according to derek bell even purportedly
good outcomes
like for example a rising black middle
class that was just the system
perpetuating itself
by basically granting crumbs to people
who had been historically downtrodden
okay th this this is what critical race
theory is and it has been mainlined
into the democratic party at this point
it is deeply unpatriotic it suggests
that the origins of the country are
rooted in racism and slavery and evil
and suggest that every institution in
american life is shot through with that
now
if republicans sound off against that
this is now considered unpatriotic
by our mentors on the american left so
cnn's don lemon did an entire
segment explaining that actually
critical race theory is more patriotic
than patriotism itself
when he interviewed kimberly crenshaw
kimberly crenshaw is most famous as the
founder of the intersectional theory of
of law and politics intersectionality
started off
as a basic fairly true theory which is
that
people can be discriminated against in a
variety of ways so
it's if you're a black woman you can be
discriminated against
on the basis of two characteristics
being a woman and being black now as it
turns out actually black men have have
lower economic outcomes in the united
states
than black women do but put that aside
her basic theory was
that if you're a member of several
different intersectional groups the
intersection of those groups created
your identity
and that was how you would be treated in
american life okay which
is really reductionist because it wasn't
just that she was making a legal point
which is that
discrimination law didn't account for
multiple patterns of discrimination
which is a fair legal point she was
making a broader point has now been
extrapolated from that which is that if
you are a member of various
victimized groups this means that almost
like a tally sheet we can determine how
victimized you are
in american life and give your views
greater legitimacy because you are
speaking
as a member of various historically
victimized groups here's kimberly
crenshaw defending critical race theory
which is what the democratic party is
pushing
critical race theory is basically just a
name for let's tear down all of the
systems
and restore systems of actual
discrimination reverse discrimination
in order to restore some sort of
equality of outcome
critically theory just says let's pay
attention to what has happened in this
country
and how what has happened in this
country is continuing to create
differential outcomes
so we can become that country that we
say we are
so critically theory is not
anti-patriotic
in fact it is more patriotic than those
who are opposed to it because we believe
in the 13th and the 14th and the 15th
amendment
we believe in the promises of equality
and we know we can't get there if we
can't confront and talk honestly about
inequality
okay that's just untrue okay so when she
says that proponents of critical race
theory believe in the 13th 14th and 15th
amendment derek bell
explicitly says that he doesn't believe
in processes like due process
that he doesn't believe in things like
equal justice before law
right those are those are merely fig
leaves for systems of white supremacy
and racism what she's talking about is
not actual critical race theory
what she is talking about is is
something broader and simpler and and
and really not associated with crt
right she's saying something that is
true which is that history has an impact
on the present
but one thing that you'll notice from
critical race there is they did they
actually don't want to attempt to even
quantify
what impact history has on the present
because quantification
could lead to the conclusion that the
vast majority of disparity today is not
the result of historic discrimination
the vast majority of disparity today is
the result of individual decision making
that is not equally distributed by
communities right that is what critical
race theory does not want to argue
okay well so these folks are making that
argument that deeply undermines
uh basic and fundamental american
principles
and then they're surprised when there's
blowback and they suggest that any
blowback is evidence of your racism
again it's it's trying to create these
sort of
unfalsifiable theses so the thesis from
the left on january 6 that's
unfalsifiable is the right is
responsible
for january 6 broadly speaking and if
you say no we're not then that's just
evidence that you don't take january 6th
seriously
and they're doing the same thing with
regard to american racism they say that
if you oppose crt
it's because you're a racist and if you
accept crt it's because you're accepting
your own racism
and and not only that if you oppose it
if you oppose crt and you point
out the shortcomings of people like
nicole hannah jones who's a provaricator
and a liar
if you point out that she should not
have a tenured position at a major
american university because she is not
qualified to do so
because she has fabricated history
because she ignored criticism
because she has doxed people because
she's a terrible candidate to be a
professor at a major university
then this means that you're a racist
we'll get to nicole hannah jones and her
fate at university of north carolina
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact
that if you need a great night's sleep
you need a mattress personalized for you
this is why you need
helix sleep helix sleep has a quiz it
takes just two minutes to complete
it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from they've got soft medium
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your doorship for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again
helix is awesome you don't need to take
my word for it helix is awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by both gq and wired magazine just
head on over to helix sleep dot com
slash ben
take their two minutes leave quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you absolutely
will helix is offering up to 200 bucks
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com again that is
helixsleep.com my wife and i have a
helix sleep mattress it was personalized
for us we sleep like babies on it when
our babies allow us to sleep on it
go check out helixleep.com right now get
up to 200 bucks off your mattress order
and two free pillows helixsleep.com
ben alrighty so the university of north
carolina
has now rescinded in a 10-year offer to
16-19 project author nicole hannah jones
she should never have been offered this
in the first place according to a report
by nc policy watch
unc is backing down from offering hannah
jones a ten-year position at its
journalism school because she's not a
journalist
well instead they will offer her a fixed
five-year contract according to a report
by nc
policy watch the change in plans comes
three weeks after it was announced that
she would have a tenured position at the
university which is kind of incredible
that she was just offered tenure right
off the bat usually you have to earn
your way into tenure at a major american
university particularly if you have no
academic background
the way nicole hannah jones has no
academic background she's not a
professor she's not a phd she hasn't
taught at a major american university
very weird to be offered a 10-year track
position right off the bat
that's very strange okay it's
disappointing said susan king dean of
unc hussman school of journalism and
media
it's not what we wanted i'm afraid it
will have a chilling effect okay so
first of all
unc yeah if they wanted to hire her and
they knew this going in
they should give her frankly i think unc
should give her the ten year track
position because i think that people
should recognize unc for what it is
but should they ever have offered it to
her no they should never have offered it
to her because she absolutely does not
deserve it
she's a 100 not a person who deserves a
10-year track position
or a 10-year position right off the bat
at a major american university the fact
that she was granted it is just evidence
of how deeply crt has seeped
into the american system of thought so
there are a lot of people on the left
who are saying that's cancelled culture
if nicole hannah jones is not given a
10-year position at university of
north carolina okay well here's the deal
should again should she be canceled
should she lose that position she never
should have been offered it and it's a
taxpayer-funded institution university
of north carolina taxpayer-funded
institutions are not the same as private
universities if she'd been hired at a
private university i would say she
should keep her job
if she's a public university that's your
taxpayer dollars taxpayer dollars are a
very different thing
alrighty meanwhile cryptocurrencies you
may have noticed took a serious
dive over the course of the last couple
of days according to the uk
daily mail bitcoin has rallied after
plunging below the 40 000
mark for the first time in more than
three months as tesla boss elon musk
insists the company will not sell any of
its holdings in the cryptocurrency
despite the turbulence celebrities and
others who bought in early are still up
big but small investors who jumped on
the bitcoin trend in the past few months
may have suffered some ruinous losses
this is one of the problems with bitcoin
right now is that because the amount in
circulation in terms of being used by
that many people is still not that high
it can be disproportionately affected by
swings from celebrities
who decide that they're not going to
engage in more bitcoin use
for example investors had rushed out of
cryptocurrency earlier wednesday after
china sparked a market panic when
officials announced a regulatory
crackdown and this just demonstrates by
the way
how important bitcoin is going to be for
the future of
economic freedom because more and more
governments are going to start cracking
down on bitcoin in the same way
that during the 1930s government started
cracking down on the private ownership
of gold
because if you can trade in currencies
that are not government currencies
this allows you to divest from the
government's inflationary policies
and this is the thing that the
government cannot allow this has always
been my great fear
for bitcoin which effectually is just a
form of
precious metals that has been that has
been digitized
that's really all that bitcoin is the
volatility in bitcoin right now
is ineffective nobody knowing whether or
not governments are going to even allow
the circulation
of bitcoin but long-term i'm not sure
that governments can prevent it
which is why i've been a bitcoin fan for
quite a while
the the bitcoin had hit like 30
drop before it retraced most of its
losses after elon musk's
vote of confidence by late afternoon
trade in new york the currency was still
down about 10
on the day but well off its earlier lows
musk indicated
that his company would not sell any of
its bitcoin holdings he tweeted on
wednesday morning tesla
has diamond hands diamond hands is slang
popularized by wall street bets which is
a reddit forum indicating a refusal to
sell even in the face
of falling prices tesla stock was down
about 2.6
in afternoon trading good for musk for
pushing bitcoin frankly
he said i know one person wrote on
reddit i know today looks terrible and
lots of people lost too much money they
can they can't afford to lose
but markets always bounce back so let's
not do rash decisions life is more
important
that of course is is true long term
bitcoin is going to be something that i
believe remains worthwhile particularly
as governments try to stop it in fact
again the value in bitcoin lies in the
fact that governments are going to try
to stop it
in the first place alrighty in just one
second we are going to get to joe
biden's continuing gafftastic journey
through the universe it is pretty
incredible as i've said before
joe biden must feel like the luckiest
guy in the world every morning because
he wakes up somebody tells him he's
president and then he realizes for the
first time every single morning that
he's president it's like a
it's like christmas every morning for
joe biden he wakes up in the white house
like
where am i like you're president he's
like oh my god that's it
come on man alrighty coming up we're
going to get to
joe biden's continuing journey it is
it is amazing to watch first some bouts
of political correctness some write
entire books revealing its insidious
roots
michael knowles has now actually written
a book with actual words
in his new book speechless controlling
words controlling minds knowles
masterfully breaks down the history of
political correctness and what america's
future will look like if we don't stop
it's growth it actually is a good book
i'm actually proud of michael he wrote a
book with words in it that is good
so go check it out right now
speechlessbook.com pre-order your copy
today or if you want an extra personal
touch
text speechless to 53445 and order
a signed copy don't wait pre-order your
copy today understand the pc police
better than they understand themselves
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
well meanwhile joe biden is um
continuing his journey
toward senility and we all get to watch
it in real time it does make for
exciting tv yesterday he was speaking to
the coast guard
and he sort of randomly insulted the
coast guard class because they weren't
responding to the fact that he is
the least inspirational politician in
modern american history
he is just a house plant of a human here
he was yesterday getting weird
i can only assume that you will enjoy
educating your family about
how the coast guard is quote the hard
nucleus around
the navy forms in times of war
you are quite you're a really dull class
i mean come on man is the sun getting to
you
i would think you'd have an opportunity
when i say that about the navy
to clap it
oh my god
he's the one who's running this radical
agenda oh great
perfect yes we've all made an excellent
selection okay that was only round one
so the teleprompter really knocked him
down right there
and i mean it was an ugly knockdown i
mean he had a he was cut
there he they in this corner the manager
was stitching him up a little bit
then he came back out for round two and
he really started jabbing at the
teleprompter and then the
teleprompter unfortunately came up with
just a clean uppercut here is the
teleprompter versus joe biden
here we go i brought with me a former
academy grad
who now serves as my coast guard millet
lieutenant commander
janet now i'm going to embarrass her
janet mccrone of the class of 2007. down
he's down oh the teleprompter oh
strong overhand right from the
teleprompter and the president is on the
canvas
uh he's struggling to his feet he's
struggling he he's up
he's up he waves off the referee he goes
in and
and oh no the teleprompter is on him
again
we need to see more women at the highest
levels of command
we have to make sure that women have the
chance to succeed and
thrive throughout their careers there's
a saying we use in a different context
the chinese saying it says
women hold up half the world
it's an absolute stupid position
not to make sure they represent at least
half of what we do
okay so teleprompter comes with the
clear tko third round the president goes
down again
the teleprompters i mean it's like the
washington generals versus the
harlem globetrotters here i mean this is
it's ugly the teleprompter wins every
single time i'm not even sure what the
point of these fights is and
anymore meanwhile kamala harris yeah
she's standing in the wings and the pr
as i've said before the problem for the
democratic party is their reliance right
now
on two things they're reliant on the
continued viability of joe biden as a
political figure and they're reliant on
being able to keep donald trump in
january 6th front and center
keeping joe biden's viable political
figure is not great because
the reality is the person standing
behind him is deeply unpopular poll on
kamala harris a little bit earlier
last week demonstrated that her
unfavorable ratings are underwater she's
unfavorable 41 favorable and really bad
ratings with independence her ratings
with independents are like 50 percent
unfavorable people do not like common
harris by the way you know why
because nobody likes kamala harris even
joe biden doesn't like kamala harris
apparently according to edward
isaac devere who is the author of a of a
new book
about the 2020 election apparently
first lady dr joe biden doctor the
greatest doctor of all time
she apparently used a naughty turn of
phrase in 2019 after commemoral harris
took aim at joe biden
the incident came as a result of that
election cycle second democratic
presidential debate
in which kamala harris randomly called
joe biden a racist for opposing forced
bussing
apparently the first lady opined a call
with supporters quote
with what he cares about what he fights
for what he's committed to you get up
there and call him a racist without
basis
go f yourself this is the first time
i've ever liked dr jill biden
she's truly a doctor a wordsmith power
excellence
according to the author doviri says the
debate was just one night in the
campaign but what it revealed about
biden and about harris
and about how issues of race and
identity factored in for democratic
primary voters had implications that
stretched into the running mate
selection process
and beyond the report said jill was and
is the guardian of the biden honor the
biden id she couldn't bear to watch a
woman who called herself a friend of her
sons
although bo is not her biological child
she raised him her entire his entire
life as if he were try to tear her
husband down to score a point
at a debate well apparently they got
over that rather quick but there's a
problem for them
and what happens come 2024 if you're the
democrats the next few years do not look
easy
if you are the democratic party if you
forecast this out
the economic growth is not booming the
way that it was supposed to
joe biden is responsible for an
inflationary cycle that is beginning
right now maybe it gets under control
maybe it doesn't joe biden is
responsible
for continuing chaos in the middle east
he's responsible for continued divisions
here at home he's continued for
continued con
he's responsible for continued confusion
over over masking
and over coved and over all of this
stuff
i mean even though americans are
starting to feel like we're pulling out
of the woods on covet
he's still got a cdc director out there
saying that we're not out of the woods
and that we still have to be super
careful
like the mixed signals coming from this
administration are quite astonishing
here's the cdc director rashel bolensky
terrible at her job yesterday saying
well you know we're still not out of the
woods yet
i think we would be remiss to say that
um
we are out of the woods um this this
pandemic this virus has
sent us too many curveballs to say that
we um
too early to declare victory um
certainly with iris circulating in other
parts of the world that is
in high degree that uh gives the
opportunity for more variants to emerge
um so i still um it's among the things
that keeps me up at night
okay for uh so you're still trouting out
rashoblenski who's awful at this job
talk about how she's staying up at night
okay we are down to the lowest level of
daily cases measured
since like early march right march of
the beginning of this pandemic
right we had as of may 19th we had
something like 28
500 cases in all of the united states a
country of 330 million people
the last time that we had 28 000
diagnosed cases in a day
was like june of last year
okay and that's when that's when the
testing was way lower than it is right
now
the baseline at that point was much
higher than the actual number of
measured cases
the number of coronavirus deaths on a
day-by-day basis in the united states is
down into the hundreds
okay so yes we are basically out of the
woods at this point but biden's been
continuing to trot that out so
what does this mean it means that this
administration is a bit of a disaster
area and the person standing in the
wings is deeply unpopular and this is
why
for for all that is holy they have to
keep the focus on trump they have to
keep the focus on january 6th
they must because if ever the focus
shifts to the democrats the democrats
have real troubles come 2022
and even bigger troubles come 2024.
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airs
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowski
editing is by adam sciovitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the mat wall show we talk about
the things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show